marty c'est bruce wayne plutôt que la
violence face à la délinquance qu'il
fallait peut-être mieux d'essayer
d'envoyer ta force et apporte une aile
pour amener plus de qualité et plus
d'éducation dans la société et pasquet
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce cas l
émission qui parle de livres qui parlent
de sciences humaines
pour ce septième épisode on va
s'intéresser à deux sociologues français
génome et monique pinçon charlot et
michel pinçon les livres de ces deux
auteurs s'intéressent principalement aux
classes dominantes et plus
particulièrement à la façon qu'ont ces
classes dominantes d'imposer leur
stratégie est d'ancrer ces stratégies à
la fois dans leur philosophie et dans
leur pratique dans cet épisode on va
principalement s'intéresser aux livres
la violence des riches publié en 2014
c'est un livre assez dense avec mal de
concept donc on va essayer d'y aller
doucement
et ça commence maintenant à l'évidence
la violence ça se limite pas aux juifs
et aux pinces et on ça va même plus loin
que tout ce qui est crachats et les
insultes
ici la violence c'est conçu comme une
dynamique qui permet aux dominants
d'imposer leur volonté aux dominés selon
le dictionnaire et j'aime bien partir de
définition du dictionnaire
la violence est considéré comme un abus
de force est en fait c'est bien cela
dont il s'agit c'est à dire que les
dominants vont enfermer les dominés dans
une espèce de fragilité qui va les
empêcher de contester l'ordre établi
vous semblez oui en effet les amis que
vous n'êtes que des salariés
c'est à dire les êtres les plus
vulnérables du monde capitaliste des
chômeurs à puissance le chômage le
chômage et son cortège de misère y
avez-vous pensé
selon les auteurs c'est cette dynamique
et c'est cette violence qui va empêcher
par exemple certains ouvriers de faire
grève ou de contester de pauvre con et
prennent pour des terroristes ou des
preneurs d'otages
et c'est aussi cette violence qui va
faire que un patron peut être payé 100
fois plus voire même plus que ses
ouvriers
c'est cette dynamique et ses stratégies
qui vont finalement faire que le plus
pauvre pas se rendant coupables des
dysfonctionnements du système dans
lequel nous évoluons tous aujourd'hui
avant de préciser j'aimerais préciser
quelque chose que je pensais m'être
qu'en fin de vidéo
c'est à dire que ici quand on parle de
riches on parle bien des grandes
richesses
on parle de l'aristocratie et de la
grande bourgeoisie non pas de la petite
bourgeoisie ou de la classe moyenne
supérieure
c'est important de le préciser
maintenant parce que ça va permettre de
mieux cerner de quel sujet on parlait de
quel fonctionnement classe on parle je
pensais m'être qu'à la fin mais je pense
que c'est important de président début
je leur précise ray quand même à la fin
dans les critiques qu'on peut
éventuellement adresser au lit la
seconde est qu'il ne s'agit pas ici
d'une théorie du complot n'est pas de
dire voilà ce que les grands et les
puissants manipule derrière notre dos il
s'agit bien des faits de système et
notamment c'est ce qu'on a appelé la
conscience de classe qui vont permettre
à certains de développer des stratégies
internaliser qui vont reproduire ces
inégalités et qui vont reproduire ses
effets de domination au travers des
travaux des deux auteurs c'est bien ce
constat là qui revient en question et on
va essayer de voir je te demande quelle
façon il est remis en question et
éventuellement les critiques qu'on peut
apporter également à ce livre donc comme
d'hab on va faire un petit détour du
biographique à l'apprendre préciser
qu'ils sont des auteurs avant de
s'intéresser à leur concept donc monique
pinçon charlot est issu de la moyenne
bourgeoisie de province puisque elle est
fille d'un ancien procureur de lozère
niché le pinson quant à lui est issu
d'une famille ouvrière
des ardennes ils se rencontrent tous
deux à l'université et ils se marient en
1967 ils vont faire un service national
en collaboration au maroc puis ils vont
terminer leur formation de sociologue à
l'université libre de vincennes donc à
partir de là ils vont commencer leur
travail de recherche avec pour lui un
focus qui va être porté sur le monde
ouvrier et pour elle elle va
s'intéresser à la thématique de la
ségrégation urbaine donc la ségrégation
urbaine c'est quoi c'est la façon dont
sont répartis au sein une ville les
différentes classes sociales et les
différentes interactions qu'ils ont au
sein de ce cadre urbain donc ensuite ils
vont commencer à travailler en
collaboration avec d'abord un intérêt
porté au monde ouvrier et à toutes les
mutations industrielles et ensuite ils
vont évoluer vers l'étude des normes
bourgeoises et nabeul ces issues de les
mèneront notamment à écrire sociologie
de la bourgeoisie ou les ghettos du
gotha qui sont des études sur le clivage
de représentation qui existe entre les
plus riches et le reste de la population
ce clivage qui est le moteur de ce livre
qui se revendique comme la chronique
d'une immense casse sociale donc ce
livre comme je le dis il est
relativement dense donc on va essayer un
petit peu divisé en trois parties qui
représente trois formes de violence donc
la violence qui est dictée par la
justice
la violence qui est dictée par le
discours économique et la violence qui
est dictée par l'urbanisme des villes
donc on va essayer de se scinder sa en
trois parties histoire qu'on puisse
avoir une bonne approche des concepts
qui sont exploités dans ce livre il
revient ça lâche 1 et la situation
dégénère
la première forme de violence est donc
lié à l'appareil juridique et à son
discours
selon les auteurs dans une
représentation sociale tout ce qui est
criminalité fraudes et escroqueries on
va plutôt l'attribué aux classes
sociales les plus défavorisées
ces fraudes des classes populaires
évidemment elle existe
la fraude aux allocations familiales
c'est qu'ils existent seulement elle est
à relativiser puisqu'elle représente
aujourd'hui 1 % de l'ensemble des 20
milliards d'euros de fraude ayant pour
chaque année en france
sachant que dans le même temps 80% de
ces fraudes sont liées aux cotisations
patronales seulement évidemment le fait
de se focaliser de se concentrer sur les
fraudes qui sont effectués par les plus
précaires c'est une façon pour les
dominants effectivement de pointer ses
classes populaires comme étant des
assoiffés de l'assistanat et
éventuellement des criminels en
puissance aussi on assiste aujourd'hui
en france chaque année à 4 milliards
d'euros dès de plus précaires qui ne
sont pas réclamés à la fois de parts et
éventuellement le manque d'informations
la complexité des démarches mais
éventuellement aussi la timidité des
ayants droit qui justement avec ce
sentiment de culpabilité ne réclame pas
ses aides auxquelles normalement ils ont
accès donc ce processus d'accusations et
de culpabilisation des classes sociales
les plus précaires elle va également
amener d'autres mécanismes comme des
mécanismes de délation au sein même des
classes populaires mais également la
volonté de chercher des boucs émissaires
et on le sait dans nos sociétés le bouc
émissaire c'est fréquemment l'étranger
dans le même temps on assiste à un
malade si sentiment d'impunité des
classes sociales les plus dominantes
passe à des fraudes autrement plus grave
ici quand vous dites par exemple que la
plupart des riches ne payent pas
d'impôts est ce que c'est vrai on a
écouté on a sorti un livre l'année
dernière aux éditions la découverte
tentative d'évasion fiscale ou là on
prouve mais on n'est pas les seuls on
est nombreux à travailler sur le
problème de la fraude fiscale il ya
quand même plus de déficit
donc tout le monde est d'accord pour
dire que c'est au moins 70 milliards
d'euros voire 80 milliards voire
beaucoup plus selon les auteurs ce sont
des pratiques anciennes et massive qui
émane à la fois d'un lac six collectifs
et individuels laxisme collectif car les
classes 2011 estiment que leur parcours
nous a fait connaître ni contrainte
ni obstacles et laxisme individuel car
il estime que le déni et le cynisme face
aux règles font partie des
fonctionnements logique et légitime des
classes dominantes
jen est fascinée dans les adouls qui
était propriétaire de la france alors je
me suis dit au nombre des locataires
donc donc on va lui devoir un loyer
c'est sarah complètement dans notre sens
les grands bourgeois d'emmener vos
espaces qui se disent comme les gardiens
du patrimoine c'est super ce sentiment
d'impunité il est clairement appuyé par
des mesures législatives
aussi les auteurs montrent qu'il ya une
vraie mise en faiblesse des tribunaux
financier sous l'impact notamment de la
présidence sarkozy
ça a continué sous la présence hollande
et c'est encore aujourd'hui réaffirmer
par la politique d' emmanuel macron
cependant la problèmatique médiatique de
cette violence et de cette criminalité
c'est qu'elle n'est pas prévisible c'est
à dire que c'est pas une criminalité qui
empêche de se balader dans des ruelles
sombres le soir mais dans le même temps
on assiste à une diabolisation de la
délinquance est également une
criminalisation des contestations
sociales et selon les pinçon charlot
face à cette problématique là il ya un
espèce de renoncement à comprendre la
première c'est qu'on a peur de remettre
en question ses préjugés sur le social
et la seconde c'est que ce sont des
problématiques qui sont autrement plus
complexe et que face à venir aimé
d'habilité et la complexité de cette
thématique là mais finalement on
abandonne un petit peu face à ces
problématiques
[Musique]
la seconde partie c'est donc la violence
du discours économique donc les auteurs
réaffirme qu en soit dans le
fonctionnement emmené au libéral il
n'existe pas d'autre objectif que le
profit cependant il est entendu que pour
les élites
ce but et cet objectif ne doit pas être
présenté comme seul et unique objectif
de leur classe sociale
paul nizan dont on a déjà parlé dans
cette émission et qui peut trouver un
auteur absolument génial je peux que
vous conseiller mille fois de lire son
livre les chiens de garde et cités dans
ce livre par monique pinçon-charlot la
bourgeoisie travaillent pour elles
seules exploite pour elle seul massacre
pour elle seule
mais elle doit faire croire qu'elle
travaille qu'elle exploite et quel
massacre pour le bien finale de
l'humanité mais elle doit faire croire
qu'elle est juste et elle même doit le
croire en cela la richesse ne doit pas
se présenter comme une conséquence
unique de l'argent elle doit également
du coup embarquer tout un tas de
discours notamment autour de l'art de la
musique ou de la culture en général
au delà de ce constat les classes
dominantes elles ont souhaité ce
perpétuel se perpétuer dans le temps et
vous qu'on va inciter à la création de
dynasty sur le bottin mondain puisque
new wave beaucoup avec le gotha mondain
vous êtes olivier de rohan chabot et je
porte le titre familial vicomte de rohan
qui est le fils du duc deuxième fils du
duc
donc c'est comme si le plus vieux et
titre de la famille ça montre quand même
au xième siècle nous vite donc c'est une
reproduction de classer cette
reproduction sociale elle est
généralement absentes du discours
médiatique en pointant pour justement
les nouveaux dirigeants de grandes
entreprises plutôt des notions de mérite
ou deux compétences en somme on à la
croyance effectivement qu'aujourd'hui
les grands patrons d'entreprises sont là
parce que ce sont des génies de la
finance sont des gens qui ont beaucoup
de mérite qu'ils ont beaucoup de
compétences qui ont beaucoup travaillé
alors quand on s'aperçoit que
aujourd'hui les grands patrons ils sont
pour la plupart avant tout des héritiers
des grandes familles
on crée un mythe de l'égalité des
chances là où il n'ya finalement kiné
égalité le problème c'est que le
discours sur l'égalité des chances c'est
un discours qui est très très bien foutu
pour justifier les inégalités c'est à
dire que on va estimer que toutes les
personnes qui sont à des postes très
élevé et responsabilités sont là parce
qu'ils l'ont mérité parce qu'ils ont
beaucoup travaillé effectivement
travailler on peut remettre en question
en base notion de mérite et tous ceux
qui sont effectivement soit au chômage
soit dans des emplois peu qualifiés
c'est parce qu'ils n'ont pas assez
travaillé et qui n'ont pas eu assez de
mérite toutes les enquêtes sociologiques
qu'on peut lire sur ces sujets là prouve
que c'est bien faut seulement
aujourd'hui les classes dominantes ont
besoin de ce discours sur l'égalité des
chances sur le mérite pour perpétuer et
pour légitimer un système qui est
hautement inégalitaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc on va s'intéresser à une troisième
forme de violence qui l'alliance des
villes ce qui est impliquée ici c'est
que cette violence des classes
dominantes elle et pas seulement
intériorisé mais qui s exprime également
à travers l'urbanisme ainsi ce que vont
dire les peintres en charlot c'est que
selon l'endroit dans lequel on habite
dans une ville on va expérimenter les
privilèges ou les contraintes qui font
propre à notre classe sociale
en cela on va dire que l'espace est un
éducateur discret mais efficace
cette ségrégation spatiale elle
s'exprime aussi à travers un relatif
inconfort pour chacune des classes
sociales de trouver dans l'espace de
l'autre
ainsi un vivier partie des classes
dominantes va pouvoir ressentir en
relatif sentiment d'insécurité lorsqu'il
va te retrouver dans un quartier dit
populaire pareil individus qu'une partie
d'une classe populaire va pouvoir se
sentir exclu à sa place quand il va se
retrouver dans un quartier dit bourgeois
ainsi ce que ça dit c'est que tous les
habitations les institutions et les
commerces qui se trouve à un endroit
donné
sont autant d'indicateurs de pratique
bien spécifiques à chacune des classes
sociales ce clivage spatial il est
aujourd'hui appuyés par des phénomènes
qu'on appelle boboïsation août et plus
facilement gentrification qui sont des
phénomènes de rachat et d'investissement
par des classes aisées de bâtiments au
sein de quartiers populaires ou alors de
rachat d'anciens ateliers ouvriers c'est
nouveau mécanisme qui l'on pourrait
faire à la fois de repousser les classes
populaires aux périphéries des villes
mais également d'effacer un certain
passif ouvriers des centres urbains au
profit
nouvelle logique de consommation donc
cette ségrégation spatiale elle a pour
objectif fondamental de préserver un
espèce de statu quo c'est-à-dire qu'à
partir du moment où on ne mélange pas
les différents individus qui font partie
des différentes classes sociales et bien
on ne remet pas en cause les privilèges
ou les contraintes de chacun et ainsi
les classes dominantes peuvent continuer
à perpétuer leur domination sur les
classes populaires
la première ici que j'aurai affaire à
suivre c'est qu'en fait il présente le
riche comme le principal bouc émissaire
de toutes les problématiques du social
sans vraiment définir ce qu'est un riche
alors évidemment eu avec tout leur coeur
de sociologues ils ont très très bonne
idée de ce qu'est un rejet de ce qui se
conçoivent comme étant un riche
le problème c'est qu'il ne précise pas
réellement au sein de leur libre un
riche pour eux c'est un individu qui
fait partie de l'élite de l'élite c'est
à dire des grandes richesses du pays des
grandes classes dominantes de la noble
de la grande noblesse de la grande
bourgeoisie
c'est ça qui a entendu parler rich et
c'est important de le préciser est
d'avoir ça en tête quand on attaque la
lecture de ce livre
autrement on à vis de faire mon avis de
se tromper sur ce qui est dit par les
pinçon charlot dans cet ouvrage la
seconde critique que j'aurais à deux
séances libres c'est cette vision
relativement linéaire du social c'est à
dire que d'un côté on a les ultra riches
et de l'autre côté on a le reste est
cette vision si d'un point de vue
partisan s entend assez bien et elle est
peut-être nécessaire aux propos de vivre
je pense que l oubli de fait pas mal de
subtilités du social qui sont
nécessaires à une meilleure
compréhension de pourquoi certains
défendent le statu quo pourquoi d'autres
défendent pas pourquoi voilà toutes les
thématiques là à mon avis sont un peu
absent du livre et pour quelqu'un qui
souhaite découvrir un petit peu toutes
les thématiques de l'affrontement des
classes sociales de privilèges de
conserver de conscience de classe
c'est sûrement une brique qui manque
dans cet ouvrage
la dernière critique et je crois que
c'est la critique principale qu'on a
adressé à ce livre c'est que ils
utilisent des outils sociologique pour
exprimer une idée à des fins militantes
c'est la critique principale qui
adresser aux livres et je pense qu'elle
a le droit d'exister ces critiques si
vous avez vu mon épisode sur
l'expérience de standford on va ici
faire un lien avec avec les conclusions
qu'on allait tirer dans cet épisode on
avait dit est-ce qu'on peut utiliser ont
pu manipuler la science pour exposer une
idée on avait dit que non parce que même
si cette idée était légitime sa décla
c'est la science en tant qu'outil
intellectuelle et s'était même dangereux
parce que cela remettait en cause
d'autres conclusions et d'autres
affirmations qui fixe à créer finalement
un espèce de relativisme face aux
conclusions de la science
là mon avis la question se pose de façon
un peu différente on va plutôt poser la
question est ce qu'on peut utiliser une
conclusion scientifique pour exposer une
idée balaj serait plutôt tenté de dire
oui et même que c'est inévitable
c'est à dire que les pinçon charlot vont
utiliser des outils sociaux logique
rigoureux ce sont des sociologues
reconnus ils vont utiliser les
statistiques les entretiens les
observations pour former des éléments
factuels sur le social après ils vont
utiliser leur expérience et leur
subjectivité pour élaborer des
conclusions sur le social avec leurs
outils sociologie on peut alors critiqué
leurs conclusions mais critiquer leur
méthode sociologique et critiqué les
faits qui font apparaître ce serait un
peu plus présomptueux et je pense même
que la subjectivité de l'interprétation
d'un fait c'est une condition nécessaire
à la création d'une idée en sociologie
comme d'habitude je vous laisse pas sans
deux petites recommandations
la première c'est le documentaire les
ghettos du gotha qui est justement
un peu une mise en mouvement des livres
qui ont été écrits par les pinçon
charlot
c'est un super film qui est réalisé par
jean-christophe rosé et donc voilà si
vous n'avez pas envie de vous taper
éventuellement les bouquins de monique
pinçon-charlot parce que je vous
conseille quand même c'est une bonne
façon de faire une petite idée de ce
qu'ils avancent dans leurs écrits
la seconde recommandation je vous fais
c'est la conférence l'approchent
sociologique des inégalités par françois
dubet pour moi cette conférence une
belle porte d'entrée vers une meilleure
compréhension 10e égalité sociale et de
la façon dont s exprime dans les
différentes strates de la société
et donc comme cette vidéo est très
longue et c'est très bien comme ça je
vais en profiter pour mettre en avant
deux amis le premier c'est alexandre
monfils qui a créé un blog qui s'appelle
mieux pensée qui est un blog qui écrit
des articles hyper intéressant sursis
appelle l'intelligence émotionnelle est
donc un petit peu aussi une façon
d'avoir une meilleure vision sur tous
les billets qu'ils peuvent habiter notre
pensée et nos modes de réflexion à la
seconde et par binh dinh hardy qui en
plus d'être une personne très sympa et
une superbe artiste et vous êtes en
train de l'écouter en ce moment donc je
mets trop le lien vers la page artiste
dans la description
car cette vidéo doit bien se terminer un
jour je vous souhaite une belle journée
soir et nuit tout ce que vous voulez et
ont dit à la prochaine salut c'est la
veille alors scott est aussi masqué
malausséna moral
[Musique]
ayant
à